aujourd'hui à scoop à la une g3 ajouté
le premier c'est lucien ginsburg
l'étudiant qui rêvait d'être peintes
l'écrivain qui publia l'aîné réf
le deuxième c'est serge gainsbourg
l'auteur compositeur surdoué que tout le
monde connaît et le troisième c'est
gainsbarre cigarettes whisky et p'tites
pépées mais rien à voir avec raymond
alors les voici tous les troy king bur
15 bouregba
bien
bonjour ça va c'est vrai c'est alors
serge commandait le petit lulu rôle qui
lui est mignon est déjà célèbre est déjà
connu il n'a pas eu de mal à peine il
est né il est déjà connu ça indique m
attention alors tu l'a appelée lucien
comme ton vrai prénom mais je veux plus
y aller tu l'a appelée lucien tu veux
qu'ils soient peintres ou écrivains
géant et qui veut c'est bosser comme toi
et je lui aurais tu voudrais qui qui
paie nous qui l'écrivons qui fasse de la
musique ou qu'il fasse les trois sets
archi architecture bâillon va se marrer
ce gamin maintenant j aime pas ça après
les footeux qui obligera pas si vous
êtes expert comptable par exemple alors
mail à mon coup de poing avec tout ce
que tu t'en vois tu avais pas peur qu'il
soit un peu mongolo lulu non il faut
faire
voyez pas peur il est mis en cause
alors imagine pas piper non mais tout ça
c'était pas c'était pas des yeux de
porto oui ma bouche pipe ray de son père
ou de sa mère
je finirai tu vas encore faire beaucoup
d'enfants comme ça c'est le dernier pas
déconner et alors imagine que tu repars
à zéro là tu remets les compteurs à zéro
tracas zéro ans comme lui et puis tu
préférais quoi avoir le goncourt ou être
numéro 1 au top 50
j'ai le goncourt
kodak et du top 50 avec les mecs bien
sûr c'est que tu veux dire direct et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu